what went wrong last time
I forgot to be scared I liked it too
much you ever think about leaving you're
so close
please stay out of trouble what if I
lost my insurance the pregnancy and
birth is gonna be about eight or nine
thousand closest place for an abortion
she said where is it hundreds of miles
away I'm sorry it's been a rough time
through a lot of people trust me if you
saw that house you'd pay us to keep it
are you gonna get the money Olli
I'll figure something out you said if I
wanted back in to come see you so you
could move say five hundred pills
I'm gonna build every day I'm with mom
and she's dying and all I can do is get
her some medication so it hurts less you
got something
yeah oxy 12 a pillow but ten for you
it's not what I wanted all right it just
kind of turn into this
I know you're selling again and I don't
appreciate losing customers because you
decided to get back in the business
[Music]
I heard you got a procedure done around
here I'm not trying to get anyone in
trouble yeah we you ain't gotta try
[Music]
it's not too late to back out how do we
know we can trust you
what brings you out this way how much
money you got and step over here we just
really didn't exactly go like we planned
[Music]
can you do this without getting caught
are you sure of course not
you
you